and we're back live here at PAX Prime at
sector G where we are running two hours
of live show demos talks with people who
are out and about at pax and generally
having the whole packs experience right
from the couch into your living room I'm
Chris waters and joining me on stage now
is Jake as doll from 17 bit he's a
project lead an art lead on galaxy Jake
thanks for coming man thank you I galaxy
you guys are on the show floor people
can play the game how's the reaction
Binford fantastic you know this is our
third packs but it's the first time the
game is like solid it's running clean we
had a couple technical snafus but last
night we got the final solid build so
we're good now nice we're in the sony
booth as well as an evening mega booth
we got six playable stations and it's
just going off fantastic they were get a
lot of great feedback and watching
people just really enjoy the game and
we're trying to get the word out that
it's not just a traditional shooter it
was a lot more to this game and so
exhibitions like this and getting to
talk to the press and stuff is really
how we get that message out that's a
great way to do it and you know we've
seen you guys at PAX before but this
game is further along than ever before
and it's a thing of beauty to see in
action so let's jump right in and give
folks a taste and you said you know you
look at it right away it looks kind of
your mind puts it in a certain genre
sure but I there's a lot more going on
here so set the stage for us so there
was a year it's a spaceship good it
looks like a spaceship game spaceship
shooter arcade games I grew up playing
arcade games all of them the story here
is that you you're kind of this fleet
goes out for a big treaty with the evil
Imperials it's a ruse this is giant
ambush everyone gets killed the entire
fleet is wiped out except for your
flagship you were the last literally the
last remaining pilot out you guys snuck
out there's to look at poyo they're all
over the place you are the last guy
remaining and you're kind of going out
and looking through these little
planetoids and these derelicts rex
looking for supplies anything to kind of
keep your chances of survival going so
you're on the run yeah she's gonna send
me in every time I start a new game I'm
gonna jump in its a roguelike so every
time i die I've had a start from the
beginning okay but as you play through
you're gonna unlock more and more stuff
that's going to start beating stock in
the shop stock yes I made that right you
got it
so I'm gonna start in here there's a
couple things i can buy to start off
this game to kind of give me a little
bit more competitive and do these
credits carry over from your previous
playthrough or do you stock starting
credit at beginning of every run it
usually you start with no cash but you
finally seem called crash coins out in
the world which you can use to buy a
couple things the beginning of every
game but most roguelikes kind of
structure up at zero again yeah we let
you if you had a good run you can buy a
couple toys to start your game off with
so I'm gonna jump it in the hangar here
and take off this might give the jury
for them okay so the trick is likely as
soon as you see this like again it looks
like a top-down sugar right and most
top-down shooters are you know you're
just kind of being drug along by the
teeth and you just sort of brainlessly
shooting all the enemies you can find
yeah just dodging the bullet hell that
is coming at you exactly this is much
more of an open world II sort of
experience it's all Newtonian physics
driven so you can see here I've got
completely it's my favorite kind of
physics I've got complete control over
the ship the controls are really lyrical
I mean just flying around as you get
better at it flying backwards and
zipping through things it feels
fantastic that leave there's really a
lot to it and you can tell i mean i'm
sure the sense is heightened when you
actually have your hands on the
controller but you can tell by looking
at the ship that there's some inertia
there that you know you're not just
turning on a dime and going to wherever
the controller you know exactly have to
incline the analog stick there's a lot
of sort of responsibility for the player
really i mean there's a lot to it this
really is sort of a tactical dog
fighting game we've teamed up with a new
company called cynthians it's doing
middleware for AI a hot the AI in this
game I would put up against anything I
put up against Park I put up as halo it
really is that level of competition so
you know it's more of an adventure game
than anything
metroid but like the imagined halo
combat but I relate to think this is
halo and 2d actually is closer to park
cry because you like there's enemies
that are out of patrols you don't know
where they're going to be everything's
procedurally generated so every time I
come in here I don't know who I'm gonna
come up against or where you can see
these early warning arrows here just
bunch of Imperials out for my right and
a buzz off of my left all the enemy
factions are also at war with each other
conveniently so if you get kind of
ganged up on the best thing to do is run
and find some enemies of your enemies
and just allow the lender in melee
that's these guys on TV coming they've
got eyes and ears fishing knows you can
tell they know I'm here now aight I'd
say so I'd say that missile barrage sort
of kicked about yeah I woke them up I
had a good shot there a lot of these
guys the these are the Imperials there
their shields are kind of closer to the
traditional halo style the Pirates
shields they don't actually activate
until they are in combat so if you can
manage to sneak up behind them before
they know you're there you can get the
head in hi boy okay editor here so you
see I've got didn't exactly cup bottom
that time do Jake but sometimes you
gotta go in guns blazing it so you don't
have a shield as well yeah I've got a
shielded well that recharges my help is
not regardless I find a rare health back
but you know in the vein of something
like spelunky or in most of the rogue
lights like we're covering your help is
it's not it's not guaranteed this is a
tough game you're meant to dialogue I
mean it really is sort of an Arcadia
simulator better to preserve your health
than to count on recovering it did you
see me bouncing up walls here this is
not a game that punishes you for
pronouncing the walls it's a very
physical game it's all about the
tactical combat and it's very violent
when you're slamming around and slamming
through these guys walking over to
missing
stopping their chakras Duke I can jump
on the gameplay yeah I was gonna say you
just like jumped out of the 2d plane
there right now it's totally cheating
but it is limited and it makes for a
fantastic party so hey if it's in the
game smarter strategy chasing down the
last dude I so he'll run off and he'll
actually call for backup if his shields
are down and there's other guys in
charge they'll they'll kind of try to
interject themselves let him recharge
his shields while he gets his health
back they'll run off her for backup you
know they'll kind of mark my position
and call in for reinforcements I mean it
really is sort of a modern combat
simulator dressed as this classic old
school shooting game so we're getting a
lot of really fantastic feedback from
the show foot here this is a kind of
nickname junkyard dog he is a sound like
a mech with a like an energy so where's
the election enemy it's an imperial mech
they've they've taken her hijack he's
gonna fight that bug off for me when I'm
gonna get back into space here this guy
he's got our mailing weapon so I wanted
to stay away from him it's really trying
to close in on you yeah these excluding
barrels is tougher actually Gators you
can set them off and they'll know geesh
bouncing up everything let's trick of
those on yourself yeah fatback part I'm
out of booze I'm out of warp my shields
are down they also time to just run I
don't want to engage I want to run
there's my shields are coming back okay
now I'm gonna go take this guy out you
are still very much on fire I just want
you to know that I've noticed yeah I'm
also I've got eight minutes left all
right his shields are down I'm gonna let
him have it well it counts here well
it's a good fight these guys you know
like I said he's jumping around this is
yeah this is a tough game it's a game of
you dialogue and it's not about
memorizing anything it's about being
constantly presented with new challenges
new you know objectives and territories
and just sort of learning how to fight I
mean it really is learning how to be a
tactical combat here now how much how
sort of out is you we heard a little
self now which are those I mean those
things are red they're gonna explode
right are you floating barrels beacon
the speaking my language
I'm trying to find out what election
here we go ok so this bug I'm gonna just
drag him with me into all these guys
they all attacked him and go probably
start jumping on them again doing my job
for me gonna like this thing up oh I
miss we're gonna get them oh he's in the
blast zone and if you put a whammy on
one of them with that TNT box all right
i mean a lot of this is like GTA i love
it they call to scramble you know when
you're running from the cops you're
freaking out you're just trying to get
out just need to get around the corner
real quick yeah we believe you leave the
site with him the problem is they're not
cheating at all they really they're AI
is so good they'll see which trajectory
you headed off at where they think you
turned you know they'll call for backup
and they'll go in the inspector position
see he thinks he last saw me up there
he's gonna go look for me up there
unfortunately for him he's by himself
now and I am gonna have done him and
yeah you wanted to so isolating enemy's
trap pull them apart fighting enemies
into other actuators so we know a lot
about positional management and the
formalities management not mad it is yes
it really is you know this is this quite
that you're dealt with every time you're
always going to be out man you're always
going to be out gun so you got to think
tactically strategically using the
environment here advantage using the
enemies to your advantage you know
trying to distract them with you know
getting into fights with themselves try
to find time getting down here so I do
have a full map so is this map I
generated a new each play yeah so these
are all completely procedurally
generated every time you know it's gonna
be a new challenge every time and those
will kind of change organically to as
you play through the game and you start
to play some of the higher difficulty
levels you know the the way that the
structures are generated will change a
bit you know it gets when you're playing
at a high level it becomes a very
different games but you literally do not
want to engage with everybody like
you're just running trying to stay alive
while this absolute you know huge gun
fights that you're in are going on see
where am I going here
may be up here there we go and so what
are these are the items that are
sparking are those just sort of
environmental or viral dressing
environmental hazards that will
basically take out your shields oh
they'll divil take out your shields yeah
but you can use them by like bumping
them into enemies having them lose their
shields as well in one of the previous
encounters you were kind of pushing that
block towards the where did you know
where it was gonna go down I do you guys
have any kind of like tow hook or cable
to or sort of push beam to sort of lean
into that kind of strategy something
like that yeah there is quite a few
passive abilities a lot of different
weapon power-ups stuff like that that
are that are coming online a lot of that
stuff we're not showing just yet we're
kind of finishing up some of the design
of some of that stuff but there will be
a lot more interaction with the
environment in general so I'm almost
done now these guys that's probe got
away and he went and called on my
position so now I've gotta [ __ ] yeah
that's a lot i'm gonna get some room
between me and these guys guys look kind
of small but there's a lot of them on
the swarm ya know that your pendant oh
they got a big boy ok i'm gonna leave
now that's my cue to leave unfortunately
them a few parting shots on the way out
and let's pack a setup any ham bushes
here this is good if i let this thing go
I just missed second I cats because
there was also a tank down there maybe
that'll cascade oh so you see those
those alert things pop into just like
you have to give you the heads here
comes the party alright so again I like
to separate these guys from their main
crew take out the probes and stuff they
don't really have any weapons but
they're really good at it being really
fast keeping up with you in kind of
colony your position contracting you so
that big bopper over here can and this
is the imperial version of the sort of
high pirate hijacking these the original
or the Pirates steal these things and
refit them themselves there you know
they kind of tweak the engines to stuff
and make them real crazy so they're less
stable these things are pretty mean the
Seminoles are one of the meanest again
enemies in the game they don't screw
around so here's my warp out beacon the
problem is I need to stay in here for a
couple seconds without getting hit and
they're gonna make it really hard yeah
but this big male a unit around that's
not gonna be easy so I'm gonna maybe
kick off some of these things and run
how many seconds you need like it's like
five seconds yeah there's no way these
guys all have physics on every single
shot they have they're gonna knock me
around this guy with the sword it's not
screwing around I'm out of missiles I
met have opportunities your work cut out
for you ever work cut out for me this is
a yeah I would really wish i had some
more missiles right now but I'm gonna
I'm gonna take him out anyway I got him
Tom you got you got some moves you see
how fast he is I mean he he's breaking
contact like he knows he's being fired
on it's not like he's done I mean this
is like you know seriously cutting-edge
AI he is like you know getting out of
the line of fire and make it surely he's
got time to and returning as you or me
and coming back at you troublingly start
what I can do though is I can cut this
all yeah pick his shield ice so you oh
man don't get me Cooper said could you
make a run for the exit I mean they're
around the corner maybe I can get up
here and warm out in time yet I mean I
shot it curse you knew Tony go go go no
it's not gonna help oh so close he just
crazy all right I'm gonna take this guy
he's killing me you got to get one of
them down and I didn't stupidly didn't
find any weapon power-ups at the
beginning of the game I'm basically
operating on my super base level laser
here trying to take power-ups did you
buy the beginning i think i bought a
missile expansion and a speed expansion
well the speed has helped you out a
little bit he's not gonna let me out oh
I believe in you you could do it Jake
I'm wondering if you know there's been a
lot of changes lately I'm whatever the
shield's aren't a little overcooked at
this guy cuz I feel like I've earned a
death by now there's one there you got
one down you have lost eight missiles
for that kill oh really did you [ __ ]
yeah I just saw pop oh yeah there we go
okay got a minute friend I got something
for you here you go then with your
shields down I'm gonna get into this
closely
laying them there there it is all right
nice to meet ya okay here we go now
let's get out of here so you can see you
know defending these things are
generally the toughest guys in this
stage are gonna be defending your warp
out zone so securing the landing zone is
a [ __ ] and these guys are really smart
they're hard and it's a challenge that I
just lost my no no demos over where it
works shut up a good network that just
because perfect way to end you succeeded
you got out that was good my heart's
pounding a little bit you know it's good
the demo while you're running for your
life absolutely that took a little more
than 10 minutes is that about the
average sort of language so there's
about four or five were still working on
this but there's me for five or six of
those in a row to beat the season okay
when you beat the season you sort of
beat the game and that opens up the next
season which is gonna have some new
story steps gonna have some new unlocks
there's six seasons overall there's a
mini story arc over each one and there's
a massive story arc over the entire
process all right Jake well what are you
guys targeting for galaxies release and
what systems are you aiming to bring it
out on so we're working with Sony the
pup fun group will be launching this
holiday kind of post holiday probably
winter time on ps4 and Vita and then
shortly thereafter on PC very cool Jake
thank you so much for showing off galaxy
you folks that's coming this way coming
your way this winter on PlayStation
platforms
you